[音楽]
ブーブ麻痺あっ日本人の中4波というブーブー1点ものがすごくしある日足ごと情報
を今まで風船陸奥たちの映像がに起きました
その中で感じたのはやはり皆さん本来自分が求めない過剰なモノマネを求めるような
そういう時代になっているんじゃないかなということに気づきました
でそれの先ほどお話させていただいたように s スマートフォンだったり
インターネットの私によって二つが自分が本来は求めていないこと
そういったものまでを売りに求めてしまうこれによって何が起きるかというと僕作画
自分が本来求めていない自分とは全く異なる
a ことをしてしまったりでそういったものを求めていくようなく
しまっていますこれによって今日本ではゲーム名の病気であったり今
そういったあの婦人疾患だったとが非常に増えてきます
そこで僕自身が今大事になってくるぞと感じているのがこのバランス触れたでしたか
これが非常にこれからみたいにライブができるんじゃないかなということでみなさんに
お話させていただきません
a まとめとですねつながることを自分とつながりそして各なれる世界がつながって
いくことによってバランスのとれた生き方ができる
バランスを取れたらいい方ができることによって結果的に人様の日本後のためになって
しまうそういうてきたができるんじゃないかなということで今日はお話をさせて頂き
たいと思っていますて自分の流れとはどういうことなのか
プレアデスね
自分で r 8はなくて取れるって芸術に変化を起こせるのかやと墨書整備しています
北約今僕自身もそうでしたけども多くの人は日本の教育課程で15歳までは自分技師で
物事を決めたり自分自身で何かをしていることっていうのはほとんどありません
多くの方が大体がブルース言われたこと先生に言われたこと
偉い人に言われたことを基準に a
僕たちは常に行動を決めたり自分でアイディアを出したい
そういうふうにして a 日々を過ごしています
近づきお客が自分とつながるために必要なのは正解のはく常に自分の自分自身が遠いを
持っている国
時にはちょっかいにわかって動く力がヒューズというふうに思っています
自分得なると言い換えると自分に自信を持つことになります
はいえー
a 自分ながら実はどうするのかということがですけれども
頭では進退を浮かべこういったことになったんですけどます
僕たちは先ほどお話しさせていただいてようなのようにスマートフォンだったり
テクノロジーによってですね色んな情報を得てそれを基に自分自身がすべきことだっ
たりアイディアだったりとか前にすることを決めています
尺そういうことっていうのは基本的には頭を使って考えていくんね
で大事なのは僕たちが進退は深くへ何かをしていく
これによって a
なぜか出てくるものもですね実現することによって自分とつながったことができるん
じゃないかなというふうに思うんだ
これはの皆さんちょっと悪かったんですけどもあの苦しいなぁワークを知りたいという
だけです
で子供の時ってあの皆さんくるくるしていて生き方かどうやらないですよね
で自分自身があるん
まあ
興味あるとこうチキンに応じてどんどん生きている
頭で考えてないんだけど子供
で自分が興味だってこれ面白いなてみようかなって思うことを常に追っかけ
そういったことを常に自分自身の毎日の中でやってというわけですね
彼らの時は凄く柔らかいですしああっ
すごく自然体なんですよ
でここで皆さんが三重をぜひ約いただきたい
やっていただきありがとうござい会はん
こちら見ていただくと書いてあるんですけれども今これをやったら絶対に自分の未来に
インパクトが起きる愛では何だろうか
これを付け皆さんメモしていただいて少しばかり考えてみてください
ブーブー分離死んで何かやりたいこと are you do じゃないなぁと皆さん
もう1本も毎日いろんな情報収集したりとかあぁ4位さあし
なので僕自身はぜひも増えているのが今ご自身の人生の中でこういうことをやってたら
もっと自分の人生が良くなっていくんじゃないかと気になってるんじゃないか
左があったりハッピーなってるんじゃないかこういったことですね
定期的に自信に解いてみるこれが非常に大事になってくるんじゃないかなーと思って
僕以外
大学ている木やっぱクルー
fire の3つで会いたい人に会ってみるプロジェクトっていうのも9時に立ち上げ
ました
立ち上げた手を目次吸い取るやっているんですけども
大学生だからできることってなんなのかな a 当時18歳だと僕自身は一生懸命
頑張りました
大学でながらことできることを色々考えた結果自分自身が船会えないような人に大学へ
という肩書きを使ってあっていくことが
a 実はできるんじゃないかなということでいろんな人にアポイントメントを取って
いろんな人たちがあっていろんな人たちよ
話している
特定前からと九州をして時には政界に怒られたりとか
あのーそんな部だけならふざけなく言うなっていうね
いろいろぐらいサービスけどこういったことをやっていますか
はいこれによってでも義姉得られたものは今まで
a 自分自身の
行動基準やることっていうのも自分の親だったりとか
来人だったりとか周りに国だったりとかそういったものに決められたんだことから自分
自身で何か自分で考えて自分で感じて自分で動いていく
二重的においてくじけて変わってきましたこれによって僕自身は受信という
人生にとってとってもらいたものもできることができました a man
自分の綱が違うってことをまとめるとこの3つありますまず特に自分自身の受信ができ
ます
そして2つめに自分の大が分かります a 自分で揚げを出して行なっていく自分で
考えて行動していく
これによっていろんなスタッフの関係が切ってきたりある意味自分の行動がゆえに失敗
おきます a そんな中から色々学んだり自分で感じたりすることで自分の才能がを
買っています今の
ので自分では考えなかったことを自分では音にもようなせなかったことを自分で行って
いく
これによって現実に結果が出てきますその結果を見てまた何か色々学んでその中から
自分がうまくいったことをすごく良かったけどこれをたくさんフィードバックして
もらってことによって自分自身の怠慢というのを買ってくに向かうと言い空車
思っていますそして3つ目人気人生設計がうまくやっていきますね
自分自身で主体的にアイディアを出して
自分自身で行動を行ってことによって
自身の人生を自分で作って1機しかあり自分とつながるか秋増毛癒しの10人4校
スポットをつくろうということでですねまず自信をつけた後に次に僕たちが目指すべき
ステージ
ステップを少しばかりお話しさせていただきます
もうしたらこれは非常に今の日本にとっては大事なテーマなのかもしれません
a こちら僕らが常に気になってしまうのは
a
2被安打さですよ
こういう状態だとなかなか
ハーフ達せっかく一度きりしかない人生を楽しむことで指にあるわけですよね
僕がですねこのつながる義塾字が上手くながらことにターン者考えたの2011年1月
です8月の僕自身の父親が脳出血でこの日あこの子1歳老けるこの月に倒れましたし
すごく食 a 車
自分の大好きな[ __ ]やが a 今までとは違った
貢献私まあそういった瞬間運営メモあなたにいつまたこの時僕自身が
感じたことが自分の母親ってものをか付けて一人の人間として
一人の人物としてえええ
初めて見ることが出ますできました今まで自分のお母さんというフィルターを通して
自分の母親のことを見ていました
なんですけれども自分の父親が倒れたことによって
自分の母親が初めてひとりのおばあさんに見えました
一人の人間に見えました今までお母さんが一切心配とか不安の音とかそういったものは
ないというふうに動く自信を持っていたんですけれどもこの事件を通して僕自身はロー
かあさんたくさんぬ不具合恐竜でこういった工藤初めてキルヒアイス
いいから
僕自身は自分自身が母親に対してできることは何なのか
これを徹底的に考えようになりお母さんと一緒に向き合ってお母さんと一緒に話して
思い切りだけに共には離島に楽しむということを決意してゴミゲーところでございませ
ん
分結果僕自身は今まで投げたを加増に求めてあり何かを自分自身が求めてないものを
目指して売っていた人生を止めることになって自分自身がいつでも何でも相談できる
そういった場所外に出たく入れることができました結果的に僕自身は
生命エネルギーが若干触れて
常に実家に帰るたびに相手のエネルギーを得られる
そういった場所家族という形で作ることができました
これは僕自身が土を絵にかいた a メッセー
上げるいるだけがたとえじゃないどこにいようがどれだけお互い思えるが本当の家族な
んだ
牧師この時に初めて本当の意味での家族ということが分かりました
a 最後にをご紹介させていただきますとはいっても皆さんなかなか普段
身近にいる家族だったり大事な恋人だったり自分の大好きな人となかなか本音にハーフ
会
本当に話せるような機会という設定と思います a その中で僕自身がえっにちょっと
一線を越えパン県南的に
を行っている理由がこちらですまずありがとう
これをずっとかけられてみてください
しかぁーコープおおさかあー千住 here 家族だ
あったりとか自分を愛してる一人で人ですねこれを書き出せ時代に見てください
英語 vc も共演の妻の男女分頃やってみましたぐだからだありがとう見えないで僕
は
ながらごめんなさいっていう意味でなかなか配している
でも誕生日とかといった記念日の機会にこういったあの事をですね帰ってやってみるん
ですね
そうするともうすごく深いいくながら混ぜます暖かい時間を過ごします
普段言えなかったと2人で走りをなります
これによって顧客の中に自分自身が心の底から安心でき
a そういった場所ができる思います
え僕たちの人生マドンが急激によって
ブービーいくように4分愛媛大敬意意見をご連絡しますしかし僕自身家族というのは
ある位に
充電器のような場所充電できるような場所として捉えていくことが非常に大事だと思い
ますし
こういった場所があるからこそ僕たちは日々いろんなことにチャレンジした3
いろんなことに取り組めたりするんではないかなというふうに思っております背景黒
自身が厚ホ
まあこのコミュニケーションっにハァハァしてたんですけども
ロス
プランん
のこの結果
こんな風に a 革命ましたこれはですね upon 6人が明鏡していて二僕の子供
が勉強しているいつもお姫に来るんですけども
9ポイントビアなることができました
はいええええに入れてる世界が来ないですね
大きな傘用のフェイ
自分とつながって自分自身に自信がついてそして大事な人とつながって常に甚平できる
自分して怪獣を感じる場所がでくださいそしてその後に初めて世界とつながっている
ことで自分自身が世界に代筆世の中に対してできることが物資を自然に見えてくると
思います
僕自身は大学店時ずっと悩んでいましたが自分の使命とは何なのか
て自分自身がへ人生を全うした人生通して本当に焼いておきたいことは何なのかずっと
考えていました
しかし分かりませんでした
そして僕自身それは一応を忘れて先ほどのステップ
まず自分自身が自分のアイディアを出し自分と繋がっていくとそして次に自分の家族
まず自分のかなとしっかり髪違って自分医師の家族が幸せにそしてハッピーに入れる
ような
後藤氏ということこのステップを技なんだへ
gree こっちのステップにことによって自分がやるべきこと自分が
人生を通して世の中に対してできることっていうのが分かりました
アルヴィン自身が自分自身にとって
大事な存在であると自分自身が自分のアイディアをし舌に行動できるようになって
そしてお家に帰ったらええ
220年できるそして相手を感じる場所が出来たときに初めてこの段階で告示しは
世の中のことをフラットに
そして税リングで楽しめるんじゃないかなというふうに思っています今まで僕たちの
人生
もしかしたら誰かの言葉が常に陰なったり何かピンなんてなかなか現実を楽しめなかっ
たりエンジョイできなかった人もいると思います
しかし自分物
さらに家族とつながれることで改めて世界というものをありのままにそのままの角度で
見ることができるんじゃないかなというふうに思っております
ええまあそこで僕自身がまあ自分の経験から
名わかったことが世界に出ることはポール
違いは字幕です
違う味は見ることまあそういった意味で最近では海外の方も日本に行ったりとか
まあまあ日本の方も大概200回出るようになっていろんなものを見るような時代に
なったと思うんですけどその中でいろんな違いをみたい
色んなものを見たりしていく中ねえっ何が起きるかというと自分自身が本当にできる
ことをわかっています
ながら2つっていうのは同じようなものとか常に同じものにプレゼント自分ができる
こととか自分自身痛い過ぎることはないです
けれども色んなものを見たりいろんなものを感じたりすることによって自分が保存
できること
自分がやっていることっていうのがあって得を占領が出るんじゃないかなっていう
早いねぇです
今回の皆さんにお伝えしたいのはあの3つだけ自分のつながりそして家族なり熱戦外と
つながっていく
これが非常に大事になってくるそしてその世界とつながることで初めて
順
自身ができることが自分数が世界に対してまぁこの cd を通してやりたいことが
見えてくる
映像ができるんじゃないかなというふうに思っていますというわけですね
影響はこの3つのお話をさせていただきました a
好きですねまずプリカ人になるんですけれども
まず皆さんの自分自身のアイデアを信じて行なっている鳥によって主体的な生き方に
代わって自分に自信が出てきます自分に4月ということもあり自分で悩まなっており
ますそして自分で取れなくなった時に自分の大事な人だったり自分のカード
か r 一線を越えかあそれずに一線を越えることで越前 to here 自分自身
が
ん
嬉しかった解けする喜べおばあちゃんないとかそういった場所ができます
そういった本当の意味でのつながりができることによって改めて世界というものをこの
地球というものをありのまま
フィルターを通されて見えるようになります
アナマガ船にクリア位になったでは状況でまた世界を見ていく
剛拳をしていくことによって自分自身が人生を通してやりたいことやるべきこと自分が
よの駆け足でできること
こういうのは自然に見えてくると思います
ですのでぜひ皆さんと一緒にこれから自分自身とつながりそして大事なショット
つながりそして世界とつながっていく
こう言って生き方が曇りできればいいのかなというふうに思っています今日はご静聴
ありがとうございました